la france doit être débaptisé des rues
et des monuments des moules au nez des
statuts au nom de personnalités
esclavagiste c'est ce que réclame en
tout cas plusieurs associations et
collectifs à paris la statue de jean
baptiste colbert devant l'assemblée
nationale a été prise pour cible lors de
la manifestation en mémoire d'un amas
traoré ce 13 juin
alors jean baptiste colbert l'ancien
ministre du roi soleil qui fut à
l'initiative en 585 du code noir qui a
légiféré l'esclavagisme doit-on
déboulonner sa statue qui trône honte
devant le palais bourbon c'est l'objet
de notre face à face et pour en débattre
nous sommes en direct avec kevin bossuet
historiens à ses côtés
ghislain un bedeau président du conseil
représentatif des associations noires de
france bonsoir à tous les deux merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
estimez-vous légitime cette envie de
déboulonner ses statuts liés à
l'histoire coloniale on commence par
vous kevin bossuet si vous voulez c'est
parfaitement ridicule je dire pourquoi
déboulonner colbert enfin c'est ridicule
c'est à dire que tous ces gens qui
réclament le fait de déboulonner les
statues notamment de déboutonner colbert
s'en prennent finalement au peuple
français s'en prenne à sa civilisation
s'en prenne à sa culture s'en prennent à
son identité et on assiste en fait à une
véritable guerre culturelle notamment
contre à l'encontre de ce qui est la
base notamment de la culture et de la
civilisation de française veut dire
l'histoire de france elle est riche
histoire de france elle à ses côtés
parfois noires à lacets côté parfois
glorieux mais il faut l'assumer tel quel
puisque c'est ce qui nous a permis
d'être ce que nous sommes aujourd'hui
c'est à dire français geste à un voeu il
faut assumer
l'histoire de france votre réponse il
faut assumer l'histoire de france mais
surtout aussi ce qu'il faut dire c'est
qu'il faut rappeler aussi le contexte
historique c'est à dire que colbert a
été à l'eau à l'initiative de l'est
2 du code noir le code noir il faut le
rappeler et c'était ce document soit
disant juridique qui était censée régir
les droits des noirs qui étaient des
esclaves et donc où ils étaient
considérés comme des objets des biens
meubles
c'était en 785 et donc effectivement la
france 2 785 n'est pas la france de 2020
aujourd'hui en 2020 on a besoin de héros
qui rassemble et pas de héros qui divise
tant qu'on aura à ce type de héros eh
bien on opposera des personnes qui
diront vos héros sur nos bourreaux et
bien puisque nous ne voulons pas des
héros qu'ils soient nos bourreaux nous
avons le devoir aujourd'hui de
construire ensemble en des héros qui
nous rassemble et non qui nous divise et
kevin postuler à ce qu'on peut vraiment
dire effectivement que colbert est un
symbole de l' esclavage c'est un héros
qui diviserait mais évidemment que non
je veux dire que le père c'est un
personnage historique important ne peut
pas le réduire seulement au code noir
d'ailleurs j'y insiste sur le fait qu'il
n'a pas à l'écrit le code noir un
colbert c'est un grand ministre de louis
xiv c'est quelqu'un qui est à l'origine
de l'état moderne c'est quelqu'un qui a
à l'origine du code forestier c'est
quelqu'un qui est initiateur notamment
de la manufacture des gobelins et c'est
tout cela que l'on salue à travers que
des bears il y à une statue colbert
devant l'assemblée nationale en fait on
honore le serviteur de l'état français
ce n'est pas autre chose et boire à
travers cette statue notamment une
glorification de l' esclavage est
évidemment ridicule la vérité c'est que
tous ces militants qui réclament cela
non je le répète qu'une seule volonté
s'en prendre à l'identité française
parce qu'il n'aime pas ce qu'est la
france
on est véritablement dans l' envie de
remplacer une culture par une autre et
c'est dramatique et moi j'insiste
beaucoup si vous voulez sur le mouvement
antiraciste enfin moi je trouve ça
scandaleux
ces gens prétendent lutter contre le
raciste alors qu'ils ne font finalement
que promouvoir la distinction des races
fins et c'est horrible nous sommes
français
nous sommes unis autour d'une histoire
nous sommes unis autour de valeurs les
valeurs dites moi je n'accepte pas que
des gens salissent notre histoire
jce un wagon je vais vous laisser
répondre effectivement il ya plusieurs
idées combat identitaire distinction des
races les personnes comme vous puisque
vous êtes visé en l'occurrence qu'est ce
que vous êtes pour déboulonner cette
étude n'aimerais pas la france quelle
est votre réponse
et bien simplement c'est un débat c'est
un dialogue ce n'est pas un soliloque
donc cela signifie qu'aujourd'hui il
faut prendre en compte la france
d'aujourd'hui la france 2020 ça veut
dire quoi
c'est à dire que la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est raconter l'histoire de
france dans son entièreté et leurs frais
l'histoire de france dans son entièreté
c'est quoi savez vous madame et
messieurs
quelle était la capitale de la france
libre la capitale de la france libre
entre 40 et 44 c'était brazzaville au
congo
c'est aussi ça l'histoire de france
l'histoire de france c'est aussi le fait
d'avoir mis en place en 1804 81 le code
de l'indigénat le code de l'indigénat
qui a été abolies en 1946 par houphouët
boigny au feu de bois ni qui était
premier président de côte d'ivoire et
qu'il était ministre français sur la
troisième république
c'est ça l'histoire de france qu'il faut
rappeler aussi donc quand nous rappelons
que oui il est temps de mettre ses
statuts et de mettre toutes ses oeuvres
dans des musées parce qu'aujourd'hui
elles sont vandalisés et on pense
qu'elle l'aurait leur place dans des
musées et au delà de cela c'est qu'il
faut faire un travail pédagogique
aujourd'hui dans nos écoles
l'année dernière encore on enseigner
dans les écoles à nantes par exemple les
bienfaits de la colonisation
eh bien il n'y a pas de bienfaits de la
colonisation la colonisation et
l'esclavagé des crimes
c'est des meurtres et des viols c'est un
crime contre l'humanité et donc
aujourd'hui nous avons besoin de
construire des héros qui rassemble et au
delà de ça parce qu'on ne va pas se
cacher derrière les statuts ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui
les statuts sont des symboles mais que
se passe-t-il au delà des statuts c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le racisme et les
discriminations ne sont pas sanctionnées
c'est ça le problème
c'est ça le problème fondamental le
défenseur des droits la cncdh le comité
consultatif des droits de l'homme
rendent des rapports tous les ans où il
ya des discriminations l'emploi des
discriminations logement les 10 nations
à l'accès à la santé et d'éducation à la
formation c'est ça qui se passe
aujourd'hui est justement qu'est-ce
qu'il qu'est-ce qui se passe wolf les
noirs et les arabes
enfin fois plus de risques d'être d'être
violentée par la police de mourir sur
les coûts les policiers qu'elle
lien quel lien faites fait-on entre les
violences policières et les statuts et
bien c'est le mal être de notre société
et quand des populations ne sont pas
concrètement on va les célèbres sont pas
entendus des bien réagi ce matin le
débat donc on va à l'essai répondre il
ya cette idée effectivement ce de
nécessité peut-être de de réviser
l'histoire qui serait parfois pas bien
enseigné entre guillemets en tout cas
mal enseignée vous le port de l'histoire
qu'est ce que vous répondez à cela
ghislain le dos kevin p pardon oui
d'histoire et pise et d'histoire vous
l'acceptez telle qu'elle est et
j'entends qu'on en oublierait une partie
de l'histoire dès lors une part
d'esclaves âge nous parle toujours de l'
esclavage notamment de la traite
atlantique c'est à dire qui est né au
xvième siècle et qui a concerné en effet
les blancs et les noirs mais moi
j'aimerais rappeler qu'il ya pas cette
forme là d' esclavage à partir du 7ème
8ème siècle après jésus-christ y avait
notamment la traite arabe où vous aviez
des populations arabes qui ont mis en
esclavage notamment des populations
africaines j'aimerais aussi rappeler
qu'il ya une traite intra africaines où
vous avez des populations noires qui se
sont mis eux-mêmes en esclavage donc si
on est un petit peu honnête il faut être
amené cela après j'aimerais insister sur
un point également alesi finale arrivera
pas échangé je voulais vous faire aussi
écouter emmanuel macron parce que c'est
important
il affirme le président tout cas que la
république n'effacera aucun nom et
aucune trace de son histoire écoutez je
vous le dis très clairement ce soir mes
chers compatriotes la république
n'effacera aucune trace ni aucun nom de
son histoire
elle n'oubliera aucune de ses oeuvres
elle ne déboulonnera pas de statut nous
devons plutôt lucidement regarder
ensemble toute notre histoire
toutes nos mémoires notre rapport à
l'afrique en particulier pour bâtir un
présent et un avenir possible d'une rive
à l'autre de la méditerranée avec une
volonté de vérité et en aucun cas
de revisiter ou de nier ce que nous
sommes en fin de non recevoir du
président de la république kevin bossuet
je vous laisserai finir votre pensée
tout à l'heure mais je voulais faire
réagir justement j'y fais un voeu 2
essayer d'être court 1 messieurs pour
que vous puissiez un petit peu échangé
sur les deux dernières minutes
ghislain le dos simplement il faut
rappeler que emmanuel macron est
complètement à côté de la plaque
il est complètement éloigné des réalités
de ce pays parce que justement ce n'est
pas lui qui décide si on doit
déboulonner les statues ou pas et bien
c'est le peuple français qu'il décide il
faut qu emmanuel macron se rappelle
qu'il a été élu il est élu par un peuple
justement ce peuple rappelle qu en
guadeloupe et en martinique aujourd'hui
il ya des personnes 90 % de la
population sont contaminés au
chlordécone la commission d' enquête
parlementaire qui a eu lieu l'année
dernière elle a mis en avant cela au
songe aussi à en guadeloupe toujours il
ya un hôpital qui est brûlé et bien que
la république s'en occupe
moi je suis d'accord qu'il faut il
fallait qu'on raconte toute notre
histoire
eh bien oui il faudra compter aussi que
la capitale la france libre eh bien oui
c'était brazzaville il faut aussi
raconté on l'a dit tout à l'heure que ce
qui s'est passé aussi c'est que la
police nationale française est l'aîné
sous le régime de vichy en 1941
c'est ça l'histoire de france eh bien il
faut raconter cette histoire dans son
entièreté
et il faut aussi rappeler ce qui s'est
passé en haïti en guadeloupe en
martinique il faudrait raconter
l'histoire dans son entièreté kevin
dessus est effectivement peut-être pas
éradiqué mais expliqué il ya quand même
cette nécessité d'expliquer l'histoire
c'est évident il faut expliquer
l'histoire mais pas absolument
absolument pas effacer l'histoire moi je
n'ai vu j'en ai entendu aucun juif
vouloir effacer à auschwitz où il est
facile de dire que nous tout simplement
parce que ça serait ça serait effacé la
mémoire de ses victimes il y a eu en
effet dans notre histoire de l'esclavagé
quelque chose de regrettable c'est
quelque chose d' abjecte sans doute
parce qu'on ait fait c'était quelque
chose d'horrible mais de là il ne faut
pas effacer les traces de cet esclavage
plutôt essayer de faire un travail de
mémoire mettre en avant des explications
essayer de comprendre ce qui s'est passé
à l'époque pour ne pas reproduire ce
qu'on a fait par le passé
moi ce qui me scandalise si vous voulez
c'est que j'ai
en face de moi quelqu'un qui ne
s'empêtre dans le giron républicain il
remet en cause la légitimité des manuels
macron qui est le président de la
république française et qui a été élu
par une majorité de français moi je suis
désolé emmanuel macron représente la
france représente les français la police
républicaine représente la france
représente les français représentent la
république et je ne laisserai pas des
gens par pure idéologie cracher sur mon
pays ait craché sur ce qui devrait tous
nous rassembler c'est à dire l'arrivée
merci kevin je suis et merci à vous
également j cela un verre d'eau d'avoir
accepté le débat je vous laisse une
seconde je vois vraiment pas ce qu'on
arrive à la fin on arrive à la fin
peut-on imaginer aujourd'hui peut-on
imaginer aujourd'hui que parce que la
france a été envahi pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale
café hitler il est venu se pavaner
devant le trocadéro et bien peut-on
imaginer aujourd'hui qui est une statue
devant le trocadéro pour rappeler cette
histoire
eh bien non et pourtant peut-on imaginer
aujourd'hui qu'ils aient une vie une
statue de pétain à vichy
et bien non plus donc cette histoire
elle est rappelée elle est enseignée ses
victoires à l'école et donc il est temps
de mettre tout ça dans des musées et
d'enseigner cela pédagogiquement avec
merci steve
merci à tous les deux cette fois ci
c'est la fin merci